[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
two beers advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John what starts with E and
ends with E but only has one letter huh
what this envelope no God I mean I'm not
even sometimes they make me laugh even
as they make me angry but that one just
made me angry Hank I do have some good
news this week uh-huh
not a lot of it I'm not gonna lie that's
not how it's supposed to work John
people are getting in the you can't you
can't begrudgingly deliver the good news
every week you have to be excitedly tell
me about good things that happen in the
world well Hank I want that sounds great
that sounds lovely I would love to be in
a position where I could tell you good
news and not have it be begrudging but
unfortunately that that's not possible
right now so instead here's the
begrudging good news in just two short
weeks the United States is going to have
an election which is incredibly exciting
no matter what your political persuasion
is because it means that we have a voice
in our governance which puts us at the
very far edge of the bell curve in terms
of human history we should be grateful
for this and we should be excited about
it
I'm fired up about it I've looked up my
polling place you can go to vote org
make sure you know that you're
registered know where you're voting
you've got your sample ballot so you
know how to vote on all the like weird
down the ballot school board stuff which
is incredibly important and get ready to
vote make a plan to vote if you're not
sure you're gonna vote if you're
thinking like a might vote or I might
not right now I want you to find an
accountability partner I want you to
text someone you know and care about and
say listen I I'm in a situation where I
need an accountability partner and
you're gonna help me make sure I vote
before or on November 6th yes that's the
one John we're gonna vote Hank I'm so
excited to vote I used to vote it I did
oh you did I'm a person who loves
waiting until Election Day even though I
know there's a small chance that I might
die in the interim and therefore not be
able to vote well I think technically if
you're dead you shouldn't vote it anyway
even if you voted absentee they
shouldn't count it but I think probably
that's a small enough occurrence that
it's just in the margin of error
I mean first off great job by me getting
my own death into the good news of the
week I'm really proud of you John I'm in
a great headspace let's answer some
questions from our listeners all right
John Dear John and Hank you didn't
highlight this one John but I did great
oh here it is
I'm excited to find out why what if I
wanted to write a book about failing to
climb Mount Everest how far would I have
to go do I need even need to get out of
my house to say that I failed to climb a
mountain well no but I think there might
be a tension between the book you could
write and the book that any readers
would find interesting yeah I feel like
all of us could write a book about about
thinking to ourselves maybe I could
climb Mount Everest and them being like
yeah that'd be a quick book the point
though it's John the theory is that I'm
interested in this question is like at
what point do I fail at doing something
like the moment I think whether or not I
could do it do I immediately am i
failing until it happens like when does
the failure occur and and this this has
presented to me a new worldview in which
failure is a spectrum which of course it
is but I hadn't ever thought of that and
it's it like it's an entirely
constructed spectrum and I am in many
ways right now failing to climb Mount
Everest but that's okay because I don't
want to it sounds miserable yeah I mean
I'm so excited about failing to climb
Mount Everest it might be my greatest
success like I'm failing to do so many
different things right now and so really
it's about what do I value and what am I
not accomplishing that I would like to
and if I am failing at a thing maybe I
should look at that thing and say is
that even a worthwhile thing to want to
do I think Hanks working through some
pretty deep stuff right now guys
thanks Anonymous for your question I am
not sure why to do things this next
question comes from Rebecca who asks do
you John and Hank I had the exact same
crisis that hick is having exactly three
years ago and Hank had absolutely no
sympathy for me and so I'm gonna have
absolutely no sympathy for him Hank was
like oh god whatever I mean just stop
thinking about it that's literally what
he said I was like I don't know why I
should be doing any of the things that
I'm doing and he said just stop thinking
about it all right this next question
comes from Rebecca who writes dear John
and Hank I'm a biology student and I've
been growing fungus in a big block of
old coffee grounds for four weeks as you
do my tutors have told us that we are
allowed to eat our fungus after we have
recorded our results this seems like a
terrible idea
and yet kind of tempting I was with you
until the end of that weird sentence
should I eat the fungus and then Rebecca
signs off thanks cool I assumed that
Rebecca sent the email a little earlier
than intended but maybe that's just
their sign off in which case I love it
thanks cool thanks cool don't eat the
fungus and also have a conversation with
your tutors about not telling their
students to eat like Randa do you know
what fungus it is like did you implant a
specific fungus that's like a tasty one
is that like like morel mushrooms is
something good or is it just it's just
fuzzy that could totally give you a
disease or not I we don't know for sure
Rebecca but I'm also not completely
convinced that you're like 23 year old
ta knows for sure yeah so I'm gonna lean
toward not eating the four-week old
coffee ground fungus yeah at or
alternately oh god you you do eat it you
get sick mmm lawsuit right cuz that
tutors just loaded you know just like
money gushing out of the pockets of a 23
year old biology tutor that's right
you're just gonna be you're gonna be
like Scrooge McDuck swimming in that
that ta money all that Pocket lint
don't eat the fungus Rebecca don't need
that that part is not a joke do make
coffee but with regular new coffee
grounds that come out of a bag that you
opened recently John I just want to
bring up the fact that I asked like some
really long eyebrow hairs now and I
don't know how to deal with it I guess
yeah I guess I should just cut them but
like what is this thing about getting
older where your eyebrows are like you
know I have an idea I don't want to have
too much of a callback here but I
started experiencing that as well three
years ago and it's actually a pretty
straightforward thing every time you get
your hair cut you also get your weirdly
long eyebrow hairs cut and most
hairdressers are familiar with oh yes
and they're able to do it really really
well
Oh interest this is such good advice I
had no idea I figured I was gonna have
to do this myself in the mirror and I
was gonna mess it up but man
maybe I should or or or alternatively I
could just let it go and be that guy
with the giant eyebrows because the lots
of people choose that route you want to
know some other things that are gonna
happen to you in the next three years or
like do it is with that spoil it are you
the kind of person who wants to know the
age and date of your death are you the
kind of person who's just like no I'll
run with my chances oh no I want to know
everything John oh okay then I can tell
you a bunch of things that are gonna
happen to you in the next two years one
of the things is that you're going to be
injured you're going to notice your body
breaking down in weird ways and you're
gonna be reminded of that line from f
scott fitzgerald's to crack up that
begins of course all life is a process
of breaking down but in the past when
you've read that line you've always
focused on the stuff that comes after
because that's the dramatic stuff but it
turns out that the fact that all life is
a process of breaking down is in and of
itself pretty dramatic then another
thing that's going to happen is that
when you're like thirty nine and a half
and pretty burnt out and overwhelmed and
you realize that like your primary
responsibilities are to your family and
that it's very difficult to balance
those responsibilities with the
responsibilities that you've taken on
you're going to try to retire
and they're gonna call your brother and
you're gonna say I
I would like to retire and your
brother's going to say well no that's
not how it works and you're gonna say
well but no I don't understand other
people retire and your brother's gonna
say no I'm sorry but that's not allowed
so I have a update on the eyebrow hair
situation ok great so I got sick of them
and I just yanked it yanked him out bad
strategy well I would like to inform you
that about 1/2 of the eyebrow hair is
gray well yeah of course so that's
that's that's also a thing so am I just
gonna have like jut like all of my gray
eyebrow hairs will grow forever and all
my normal like youthful eyebrow hairs
will be short and in hiding behind my
giant gray eyebrow hairs Hank
buddy you're a great person but you
don't have any youthful eyebrow hairs
you have old eyebrow hairs and you have
less old eyebrow hairs all right I think
we have another question it's actually
two questions they came in to our email
within seconds of each other the first
one came from Isaac who wrote Dear John
and Hank my bossy 15 year old sister
keeps telling me to stop dad oh well but
I can't stop dabbing oh I think it's an
illness how do I stop dabbing any
dubious advices appreciated call me sir
Isaac moments later
Danielle asks my annoying
thirteen-year-old brother won't stop
dabbing how do I get him to stop dabbing
he is stuck in 2015 and I cannot for the
life of me pull him out of the past help
and they dubious advice is appreciated
don't Dan whisper or Dan speak Danielle
that's very good Danielle here's the
thing Isaac there's something about
dabbing that feels so good
I get it I totally get it I get it
because I have an eight-year-old son and
a five-year-old daughter and they love
to dab they have all of these like
iterations on the dab there's like the
rainbow down there's the infinite lab
there's the there's the speed dab where
you dab back and forth
left right left right left right left
right it all has to stop Isaac okay once
it's filtered down to the
eight-year-olds in the five year oh yeah
the 13 year olds like yourself need to
let it go that's a great point John I do
have to say that it is a lucky thing
that this is a podcast cuz I just dab
like a thousand times are you serious I
set up so many times just now in the
last in the last 30 seconds of this
podcast my kids asked me to dab but I do
it reluctantly and while I'm dabbing I
feel older than anything else has ever
made me feel I yeah I am I am
occasionally asked to dab and not so
much anymore because it is after all
2018 but like on a live stream or
something and I cannot I cannot do it
with other people looking at me but I
can do it on a podcast and I'm doing it
right now I'm imagining it and it's
extremely cringy don't put it in your
head I don't want you to think imagine
me dabbing I'm just I am and don't that
I guess that's part of how don't think
of an elephant don't think of having
don't think of Hank to having Isaac it's
okay to dab you got a dab in the privacy
of your own room there are some things
that have to happen alone especially
when you're a young person dabbing is
one of them that's right that's right
and all your dance moves cuz this isn't
the only dance move you're ever gonna
have you got to develop those while
watching MTV's the grind alone in your
room like your good uncle Hank did yeah
I mean that's weird calling yourself
uncle Hank
is weird that's okay that's okay great
old man thing that old men start doing
where they're like you know what Uncle
Hank always says uncle Hank always says
dab alone while watching MTV's the grind
[Laughter]
you know what uncle Hank always says
uncle Hank always says don't let your
old man eyebrows distract people from
your youthful library
see it's got great advice John uncle
Hank is full of good ones you know what
I'm gonna think always says never put a
cough drop in your eyeball
I got good ones lots of good advice
stuff you should definitely listen to
all right I have to end this bit
immediately it's causing me a lot of
anxiety this next question comes from
Karen who writes dear John and Hank my
brother and I are both in high school
and he's like a super nice boy but I've
noticed when he's with his friends he
tries to be more tough I don't think
this is an uncommon occurrence but I
feel bad that he can't be himself when
he's with his friends
I know his grade and I don't really
think switching friends is an option
okay encourage my brother to be
comfortable enough with his friends so
he could share his real interests and
not be such a jerk Sharon is Karen
so Karen I have a story about this but
it doesn't star like a ninth grader it
stars 37 year old me know when I first
arrived at the set of the movie Paper
Towns the only person I knew was nat
wolff I knew not because he'd been in
The Fault in Our Stars movie and and we
were friends and so I got to this big
hotel suite where everybody was hanging
out and there were all these new people
I didn't know and I was super nervous
and when I get nervous sometimes I
revert to like childhood behaviors in
really weird ways and I look back on
them and I'm like oh god that was so
horrible this is one example of that so
I see all these new people that I don't
know but you know a couple of them are
well known enough that I know who they
are
mmm-hmm and I'm super nervous and I
don't know how these people are gonna
think of me and I don't know I just I
don't know I'm totally overwhelmed and I
look at NAT and he's wearing a leather
jacket and somewhat fashionable like in
my opinion too fashionable shoes and the
first words out of my mouth are what's
up with those shoes Wow and that just
looked at me and he said well they're
the shoes that the costume director got
for Q and also I know what you're doing
god you can't get called out like that
by somebody this is like a decade and a
half younger than you that's that's hard
he's a decade and a half younger than me
but like a decade and a half wiser as
well and and he explained it to me like
I didn't know what I was doing but that
was like sometimes when you're in a room
where you only know one person you make
fun of that person as a way of trying to
like make the other people in the room
like you and you think that's a good
strategy and it makes sense in your head
partly because of toxic masculinity and
partly because of other reasons but it's
not actually a good strategy and it
doesn't actually work and maybe there is
a way to be the GNAT wolf in this
situation with your brother to be like I
think I know what you're doing but I'm
not convinced that it's effective yeah I
mean I think that we all try on aspect
like at this age we're trying lots of
different identities and we see how they
fit and and if there's like if there's a
situation where he it feels like your
brother's being pressured into being
away that he doesn't want to be and it
is it's frustrating and difficult and
hard and like that could be something
where your commiserating with him but
also like if he's finding like if he's
finding something in that that's
appealing and but also like it might be
leading to you know more like a less you
know thoughtful way of viewing the world
or you know a lack of empathy on his
part or something that you you know
things that you you don't want to see in
your brother like calling out the
identity might be a little bit too much
might be a like too much of a threat to
him you know depending on how how his
social group is is responding to sort of
like how are we going to become men
together and and so I think that one
thing to remember is like make sure that
you highlight and like and like uphold
the parts of you know your brother
growing up that you really admire and
and that you want to to admire in him
like that he's hardworking that he's
caring that he's helpful and that he's
thoughtful so hopefully you can ask some
kind of some kind of like a version of
like growing into manhood that is is
about more than like being a real man or
whatever that's supposed to mean just
just tell them like I know exactly what
you're doing when you try to make fun of
my shoes my shoes are awesome this next
question comes from lorina who asks dear
Hank and John a couple of days ago I
received a phone call and was offered a
job this job is to sit at a show and
volunteer when asked to get on stage and
go inside a magician's box and be sawed
in half wonderful congratulations on
this job was this a cold call like oh
did you apply for this job or did you
just get a phone call that said are you
looking for a job getting sawn in half
because if it's the latter I would be
highly suspicious of this gig lorina now
if you're in a situation where you
applied to be a magician's assistant
then yes this is fine otherwise I think
that you might be making a terrible
aesthetic it does the way the question
is phrased does sound like you got a
call from someone who was like I want to
give you 20 bucks to come get sawn in
half I assumed that you knew about this
beforehand because no person would agree
to this right well yeah or knows but but
we are giving you the not dubious advice
do not go and have a stranger saw you
and a half just because they called you
on the phone but such good advice for
any guy is so solid you know I really
got it we're hitting it out of the park
today Jeff it's the kind of thing that
you might not otherwise know like some
some things just don't set off your
alarm bells you know right uncle Hanks
here for you Lorena
so it's lorina says it's wonderful news
that they they're getting a job but they
have some questions and concerns I have
no idea what I'm going to do since I
have to sit and watch the same show many
many times I have no experience in this
can I bring a book with me no could I
just arrive late to the show every time
no should I get my google glasses and
watch Doctor Who the entire time
actually maybe that's that's a
one dubious advice needed pumpkins and
penguins lorina III you definitely have
to look like a plant you can't like you
have no you have to look like you're not
a bunch what I meant to say Uncle Hank
says uh you have to look like a human
being not a plant not a ficus you need
to look like I'm so excited to see my
first-ever magic show yeah what an
opportunity tonight is what you're
getting paid for and I worried that if
you bring the Google glass it just makes
you it just adds a level of suspicion
just based on the way I feel when I see
people wearing Google glass it for me I
don't want to generalize but it does add
a level of suspicion I feel toward that
person yeah just generally in all things
yeah so my I think what you're gonna
have to do Loreena is what I had to do
at the Hall of Presidents at Walt Disney
World for much of my childhood you're
just going to have to pay careful
attention to the same thing happening
over and over again and you may discover
that on the other side of what will
initially be kind of boring is this
weird kind of transcendence like
watching the Hall of Presidents show 50
times is kind of boring watching the
Hall of Presidents show 500 times is
sort of revelatory why don't you watch
the Hall of Presidents show 500 times oh
because you know you remember how mom
had like permanent lifetime free passes
to Disney World
uh-huh because she won a community
service award in Orlando huh and
remember how I hated Disney World and
Hall of Presidents is the only place
that's air-conditioned and doesn't have
a line uh-huh okay so I would just go
into the Hall of Presidents and chew
tobacco and watch the Hall of Presidents
show and then go right back in for eight
hours that's really good John that's
wonderful what a good team boy thing to
do John you just really couldn't be
bothered to enjoy the happiest place on
earth oh I enjoyed it a great deal
because I'm telling you if you watch the
Hall of Presidents show enough you will
find on the other side of it a
transcendence the likes of which Space
Mountain can
provide all right well there you have it
from Uncle John's I'm real real the
doozies of advice don't you don't chew
tobacco lorina I know that probably goes
without saying but it's one of the great
shames of my life it was really gross it
was such a weird I remember being at a
family wedding and our grandmother nanny
yeah I remember
nanny walking up to me and looking at me
and just like something shifting in her
eyes and her saying are you dipping and
me being like yeah she just like looked
at me for a half a second and turned
away that was it that was the end of my
relationship with chewing tobacco oh god
I've got a little son sure how that
sentence was gonna end no shame in Joe's
chewing tobacco over my grandmother
uncle Hank says there's nothing better
than a dip a kid get you some uncle
Hanks chaw oh man wouldn't that be great
Hank why don't we sell chewing tobacco
at dftba.com there's so many items that
we could sell that we don't yeah it's
like we've completely avoided all of the
things that cause cancer and are
addictive what are we doing yeah people
love that [ __ ]
they can't stop literally but I think
that we definitely answered the question
which is watch the magic show over and
over and over again learn about this
show yeah get into the magic show
especially because you might have a
career as a magician's assistant in
front of you or maybe even a career as a
magician if you start to figure out how
the tricks work hopefully you will
definitely know how the one trick works
hopefully that it's been explained to
you all right I think this next one
comes from Madi who writes Dear John and
Hank I am a registered absentee voter
exclamation point
I love your enthusiasm Madi I love the
exclamation point I think it
communicates correctly that we should
all be psyched about voting and we
should all have plans to vote and we
should all know where our sample ballots
and we should all know what our sample
ballots look like and our polling places
our vote or I'm not gonna stop bank I'm
not going to stop until actually when I
stop because the election is over I'm
just gonna start in for 2019 for you
exciting County Commissioner races I am
currently going to college away from
where I live and I'm mailing my ballot
back soon however as I'm filling out my
ballot I find that there are a ton of
local positions and even some state
offices that don't have multiple
candidates I find this especially
troubling because I don't agree with a
lot of these candidates even worse
there's a state court position where
neither of the candidates reflect my
views at all I can't even find the
lesser of two evils
there is usually a lesser of two evils
Maddy but that's for another time can I
just leave this part of the ballot blank
also there are some local initiatives on
the ballot concerning taxes and property
I don't own property there nor do I pay
the taxes that the ballot concerns
should I not vote for or against these
initiatives will not voting for any
local elections remove me from the
discourse of the town that I am already
physically removed from actually quite
happy not Maddy
absolute cute so there's there's two
things in there one is the thing where I
don't know how to vote in this election
just because like I don't maybe I don't
have time to do enough research on all
of the the candidates for the courts
though I would absolutely encourage you
to do that research and there are now
far more good resources for doing that
than there were even two or four years
ago so it does not take that long yeah
so that that is is oh and also the
situation where there's only one person
like do I have to vote for the one
person you don't have to vote for the
one person and and also like that person
is gonna get elected so if you want to
just save the time of filling in the
bubble you don't have to vote for that
person well not only that but not voting
for that person can communicate
something it can't communicates to maybe
people who are considering running
against that person then there might be
some support and so I think that not
voting for someone in a uncontested
election is a way of communicating your
lack of satisfaction with your
representation in that particular
elected office as far as whether you
should vote on taxes you don't pay I
think you should because your vote
about your community and it's not if it
was going to be a vote that was held
only to taxpayers it would be but it's
not it's a vote that's held to all
members of the community yeah because
you together are deciding what kind of
community you want to live in now you
may not live there right now or may only
live there part time but it is still
your community both legally and in terms
of how you think of it so I absolutely
think that your voice should count yeah
I mean there's a lot there's gotta be
voting on lots of things in your life
that won't directly affect you like like
once you are out of school and you don't
have kids or your kids are out of school
you will still be voting on ballot
initiatives that have to do with school
and so those will be taxes that you will
pay or not pay that will go to resources
that like ultimately like you care about
and and will affect your community even
though you are not one of like you are
not affected by that directly okay we
are all affected by those things
indirectly like whether there's a new
tax and what that tech supports affects
us even if we don't pay the tax even if
we don't directly use the resource that
the tax is paying for yeah getting
slightly off-topic here one thing I hear
a lot from wealthy people I know whose
kids are in private school is that they
vote against all funding for public
schools because it doesn't affect them
and it just raises their taxes and that
seems to me so astonishingly
narrow-minded in the way that we think
about how our communities worriedly and
even on a very selfish level even on a
very me based level it is good for me to
have people in my community get access
to better educational opportunities
because then they can get better jobs
they can build businesses in my
community that I can do business with
and that that is how we grow as a
community like to me public education is
one of the massive earth changing
innovations of the last 200 years and so
I really think it's important to vote on
those issues
because other people definitely feel
empowered to vote on them even if they
don't think they're directly affected by
them that is for sure John I got another
question who comes from Dalton and who
asks dear Hank and John there's a
particular spot on my chin that I cut
almost every time I shave I've tried
going with the grain against the grain
perpendicular to the grain all with
similar results I'd grow a beard and
forget about if I'm a facial hairs too
thin so it looks awful
I'm 24 so that's not an issue that is
likely to get solved with time can you
help me shave better yes I have seen
roadhouse Dalton okay John I don't I
don't like other than doing what I just
did to my eyebrow hairs and just being
like okay you guys are coming out with
tweezers I don't I don't have much
suggestion here help help Dalton well I
think the most important thing is
actually a it's having a good razor
blade okay having a really sharp razor
blade a new razor B it's really working
whether it's shaving cream or whatever
you use to kind of lubricate the surface
of your face for shaving you've really
got to work that in carefully I have a
spot that I cut probably 60% of the time
even doing all of these things because
there's just one spot on my face it's
near my chin where I don't know if the
skin is thinner or what but I have found
that if I really work in the shaving
cream stuff that I use I use like fancy
shaving cream stuff if I can really work
that in for a while and then I've got a
really nice good razor I can usually
avoid getting cut there
I also another thing that I've tried to
do though is just understand that I can
get cut there and it's not a big deal
it's not the end of the world
like I cut myself shaving right before I
was on TV for 60 minutes mmm and they
didn't have like a hair and makeup
department to like fix me up or whatever
so Sarah used this magical stuff called
makeup on my cut and it went away and as
a result of that I realized that there
is this thing called makeup that can do
a lot of different things to make your
face look better and I've been told not
to use it by the soldier
order but the social order is totally
wrong about this
which reminds me John that this podcast
is brought to you by makeup which is the
thing that you can put on your face to
make it look slightly different it's
available to people of all genders new
product out now makeup and of course
today's podcast has also brought to you
by good uncle Hank
Oh God good uncle Hank distributing
obvious advice in an old man's voice
since earlier today this practice is
also brought to you by secret dabbing
secret dabbing it occurs alone where no
one can see you today's podcast has also
brought to you by the coffee fungus in
the biology lab the coffee fungus in the
biology lab I mean they say it's edible
all right I got another question John
it's from Anya who asks dear Hank and
John recently I received a letter of
recommendation for a thing the person
who wrote it emailed it to me so I could
print it out and attach it to my
application which I can then submit is
it ok for me to read what has been
written about me not the Disney Princess
Anya
John I looked this up what the rules are
you shouldn't do it unless they say can
you read this and tell me what you think
you should you probably apparently you
shouldn't oh yeah
well I've certainly never abided by that
rule huh likewise so Anya as you read
the letter of recommendation just know
that if you it's you shouldn't be doing
that I had no idea that you weren't
supposed to do that and I have to say
I'm very grateful obviously I'm sure
that the etiquette is right and I'm
being terrible for saying this but I'm
just gonna say it I'm very grateful that
I read the letter of recommendation that
my professor Don Rogan wrote for me for
Divinity School because it in like
really hard times in my life or really
dark times in my life when I felt really
sad and felt like I'm worthless and
stupid and I just can get so angry with
myself sometimes I go back to that
letter because it was so kind and
generous and it sort of showed the best
version of me and sometimes I need to
see that myself so I mean I get I get
you're not supposed to read them I get
how that can maybe be a violation of
privacy now that I think about it but
boy am i grateful for that letter so
Hank I got a question for you and it put
me down a very deep rabbit hole that
I've only recently emerged from it's
from Laura who writes Dear John and Hank
around eight years ago my friend now
girlfriend had a jell-o pudding cup in
her lunch a common occurrence okay on
the lid of the cup a smiley face in the
letter O of the word jello had a speech
bubble saying frown is a four-letter
word we could never figure out what this
meant and it's been haunting me for
years can you lay this mystery to rest
roses are red I am a nerd what does
jello mean by frown is a four-letter
word done I mean this this isn't
something everybody knows but just like
so you've got five fingers right but you
don't actually you have four fingers and
an N and a thumb that's the case with w
w isn't technically a letter
it's its own thing it's a W ah so it's
Oh frown has four letters into W yeah
that's right that is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard W is not a letter it's a
W of God I I'm just gonna explain this
for any young people who might be
listening that is wrong all letters are
letters Brown has five letters so
there's actually a whole community on
the internet that even eight years later
is still furious about this they're
still very upset and the more I think
about it the more I agree with them like
I started out thinking like oh it's just
a dumb thing where they're saying frown
is a four-letter word so in English
colloquially four letter words or kind
of curse words like there's the S word
that's a four-letter word like bad words
mm-hmm are often called four-letter
words and I think the joke is that
frowning is bad and you shouldn't do it
because yellow should make you happy and
so jello is here to turn things around
make your frown into a smile and stop
having you say in those four-letter
words of negativity and
sanity like frown but it's the stupidest
it's stupid on every level because the
one thing it says to people who are
frowning instead of saying like I'm
sorry you're having a difficult day it
says like your experience is equivalent
to expressing yourself in an obscene way
which is not helpful your sadness is an
obscenity according by the jello
overlords right exactly so in addition
to the fact that it's like unhelpful to
people who are experiencing frowning
it's also like super difficult to parse
like it's a joke it's a joke that people
are still debating eight years later
because that's how bad of a joke it was
so I just want to say to the folks at
jello like that was terrible and if you
need advice on how to develop more
compelling advertising you should go to
noted brand specialist Hank green who is
in the process of becoming a national
spokesperson for a big big brand yeah I
don't think got really gonna put my my
weight behind jell-o honestly it's just
it's basically sugar water I'm not that
into that I will say John that we are
still talking we did say jello a lot and
and and also people are still talking
about this bad joke so maybe it worked
but maybe this was the goal the whole
time degree went to controversy have a
bunch of forum posts have people still
arguing and thinking thinking about
jello being like oh god that frown joke
was bad but also jell-o pudding cups
pretty tasty but they aren't
that's my counter-argument when was the
last time you had jello not recently but
I'd yeah now that I'm thinking about it
I kind of want some so I recently got
some jello for my kids
mm-hm and I was like this is a wonderful
dessert that I enjoyed a lot as a kid
and my kids ate like one bite of it and
they are like what the is this they
don't like just that that is an example
of a four-letter word they don't like
jello not only did they not like jello
they were like how on earth could you
have ever like ever enjoyed this it's
like if our parents
served us like sheep intestines and
liver we would have been like that's
weird like in the old days I guess
people had to eat all kinds of things
but thank God now we can have granola
bars
I mean people still like dough man
so like Millennials killed a lot of
things but like your kids generation is
def gonna kill jello is that what you're
telling me I'm telling you what comes
after what comes after millennia
Millennials yeah true Lenny Lenny bye
Lenny else no it's Halle yeah so the
poly lineal is who are coming they're
gonna destroy everything they're gonna
destroy jell-o they're gonna destroy
meat I'm going to destroy based on my
children's food preferences the the
polynomials are going to destroy all
food categories except for vegetarian
chicken nuggets that's good for the
chickens anyway okay hang before we get
to the all-important news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon oh my god the darkness
darkness everywhere I've got this
message to read from Sarah who writes
Dear John and Hank I recently started
college in Raleigh North Carolina and I
celebrated my 18th birthday this past
Thursday my wonderful parents drove for
hours to spend four hours with me and
then return they used to live here and
so took me to breakfast at a restaurant
they used to frequent called Briggs
I recommend the food and it was overall
a very pleasant experience except that I
was forced to eat an entire meal next to
a horrifying five timed fork that was
the size of my whole body I'm looking at
a picture of this Fork it is it's real
very large uh-huh oh boy oh boy it's
upsetting it is there's nothing worse
than a 5-time fork I mean there are
things that are worse than a 5-time fork
to be clear poverty disease burden etc I
attached a few pictures because it's
just so horrifying I had to share it
with someone who would understand my
family did not they just thought I was
getting even weirder Sarah no I wasn't
intentionally named after the Terminator
Connor great names Sarah and also a
really great picture we'll post it on
the patreon at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John all of your five-time
forks pictures we received many of them
we found all of them equally disturbing
and
distressing and in in one case they made
me vomit
that we this one that is that is the
size of Sarah is is a is like my eyes
can't parse it it just like it doesn't
work it doesn't make sense I can't count
the number of times it's like it's like
they found the way to hack the human
brain in that way that the the the
Federation was gonna do to the Borg with
hue with with a impossible geometric
shape but they ended up not doing it
because they thought it was immoral
which I still think is a really dubious
decision Hank that's a really great
example of a reference that everybody
who listens to this podcast will get and
it will really resonate with them
alright John there's like literally one
percent of our audience was just like it
is like that and the other 99 percent
were like I think I think I've I think I
know what the Borg is I think I need a
new podcast to listen to yeah well
there's the Anthropocene reviewed where
I never talk about Star Trek yet you
could review our Trek that was something
that Goodman's created alright Hank it's
time for the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon it's gonna be it's a darkness
I'll go first okay
Wimbledon cannot stop losing that's we
cannot stop losing we lost yesterday to
Bristol Rovers two to nothing even
though we dominated the game the problem
is that dominating the game doesn't
matter when you can't score goals and we
cannot score goals the only time we can
score goals is when we're already down
by more than one goal mmm we haven't
scored a goal when not down by more than
one goal in like six weeks or something
or eight weeks it's it the situation is
completely out of hand and I am just god
I keep it keeps popping up on my little
my little home screen because because
now Google knows that I care about IFC
Wimbledon and yeah and it should and it
just it makes my day worse it yeah like
I'm like why am I so stressed out right
now and it's like oh it's because I just
looked at the AFC Wimbledon score me too
I'm also really stressed out about it
there's a lot of talk about knee largely
resigning or knee largely I don't know I
mean that or
him getting fired it's obviously a very
difficult situation and and you know I
think everybody's dream neo hardly
played for Wimbledon when he was a kid
you know he's been a huge part of this
club's history and I think everybody's
dream was that he would lead the team
out when the new plough Lane Stadium was
finished and and managed the first game
there and and that dream now seems in
doubt also it has to be said that
Wimbledon's League position in Ligue 1
is very bad I mean the only reason the
only reason that we are not in last
place is because there are two teams
that are just inexcusably bad one of
which we've already lost to actually
know now that I look both of which we've
oh my gosh so it's just it's a really
bad situation obviously and sometimes
that leads to a change in management
sometimes I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen in the years that I
have sponsored AFC Wimbledon I would say
this is the second most difficult period
and the first most difficult period is
when they almost got relegated from the
Football League entirely and in and in
that case it was nail art Lee who came
in and really saved them and on the last
day got a win when we needed one and
kept us in the league how we're gonna
stay in Ligue 1 the season I do not know
but it is still only October and I guess
there is still time for things to change
Hank what's the news from Mars is it
gonna cheer me up no it isn't because I
also get a lot of Mars news now on my
Google home page because it knows that
I'm interested in Mars what's the news
from Mars well there is there's good
news from Mars it just isn't good news
from the Mars Opportunity rover so there
was a study recently released in Nature
Geoscience suggesting that the water
that we have found on Mars might you
know they did a bunch of math basically
let's just say weird math models they
figured out that even though there is
not a lot of oxygen in the Martian
atmosphere it's 0.14 or 5 percent oxygen
and that is a very thin atmosphere so
it's very little oxygen and oxygen is
good for helping complex life evolved so
life can happen without oxygen in fact
that's how it happened on earth but then
once oxygen is available life can use
that to do a bunch of good interesting
things with he can use that to to form
more complex structures basically and so
this this new model indicates that the
water on Mars very likely contains more
oxygen than we assumed it would and also
enough oxygen that complex single-celled
life so more complicated single-celled
life could happen but also potentially
like very simple multicellular life
could exist with this level of oxygen in
like dissolved in in the water and that
looks like sponges like that kind of
multicellular life which is right on the
edge of where single cells and multi
cells sort of sort of function and like
having like more specialized tissues not
so much but but definitely having cells
working together and and forming into
like a single organism that has lots of
different cells so that that oxygen
allows for you know more chemically
interesting stuff to get done and and so
obviously this doesn't mean that life
does exist on Mars it just means that
like it could and it could exist in a
way that we didn't know about before so
it could be like we've known for a long
time that life on Mars probably isn't
going to be like crawling around
probably isn't going to have opposable
thumbs etcetera yeah yeah but this is
the first evidence that we've had that
based on what we know about the
chemistry of the planet and the water
that we could have multicellular life
right based on what we know about about
the chemistry of that of Mars and also
based on we know about the chemistry of
multicellular life it just is pretty
cool is a requirement to have a certain
amount of oxygen dissolved in water for
that to happen and and
and many places does have enough oxygen
and for that to happen and is there
anything about the water on Mars that
makes multicellular life less likely or
impossible well if we took multicellular
life from Earth and put it in like an
analogue Martian water it would not
survive it's got a lot of harsh
chemicals perchlorates are the like a
kind like a ionic compound that is
dissolved and that is actually what
allows like these sort of salts these
salts are what allows for the water to
be liquid on the surface sometimes and
also for the liquid water that we found
substantially like you know more than a
kilometer below the surface that brine
allows the water to stay liquid even at
very like lower than freezing
temperatures
but that Brian also would would kill
anything from Earth but we know that
evolution does a good job of selecting
for things that can live in weird
situations and perchlorates definitely
are a harsh chemical but maybe if you
evolved in that situation maybe they're
just food or just you know just just the
natural environment and so it doesn't
feel that way so that's we actually the
scishow team got to talk to some of the
scientists who are on this paper and and
they were like you know like we don't
know what how life would would evolve to
to handle a high perchlorate environment
because it's never had to happen on
earth so you know maybe there would be
mechanisms that we wouldn't have
imagined but there's no existing earth
organism that could survive in what we
know about existing Martian water
correct
okay that's interesting yeah so if we
discover life on Mars it will be like
truly weird to us it's not like like oh
it's an amoeba
oh I mean like the question is whether
it's based on the chemistry of earth
life if it has like like DNA and RNA and
it uses like similar protein structures
to us because that wouldn't be something
that would happen automatically that
would mean that that life got carried
from Earth to Mars or life appeared from
Mars to earth and so we're like share a
common ancestor which is totally
possible but the the
alternate would be like totally like
even in that case it would be extremely
foreign it would be very weird it would
have gone in completely different paths
for a very long time billions of years
and but like if it evolved separately
that would be the biggest story because
that mean that would mean that life is
probably fairly common in the universe
because it happened two times on two
planets in one solar system and then but
but it would also give us a chance to to
learn I don't know like truly deeply
huge things about about chemistry and
about about ourselves by having some
other version of life to compare
ourselves to we have got to get to Mars
hey yeah you're there you there with me
now we need humans on Mars alright that
would be that would be by far the
biggest discovery in the history of
science yes correct
20:28 we don't know there's no way we're
getting humans on Mars in 2028 but we do
we need humans on Mars I'm I'm on board
I don't want to be one of the humans but
I'm 100% on board alright
well I'm on board with AFC Wimbledon
winning a game as well
God please alright well thank you for
potting with me Hank thanks to everybody
for listening again you can go to
patreon.com/scishow John if you want to
see a really very large five timed fork
and thanks to all of our patrons there
for helping support the work that we do
it complexly John before we in the
podcast what is important about Ethan
Hawke's birthday what is important about
Ethan Hawke's birthday its November 6
John vote
[Laughter]
I love it I love it vote thanks for
listening our podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and chair dan
gibson our head of community and
communications is victoria bon giorno
the music that you're listening to right
now and at the beginning of the podcast
is by the great gunnarolla and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]